[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
loisirs ravi de vous retrouver pour ce
quatrième numéro tout le sommaire de ce
jeudi 4 octobre
c'est le rendez vous bd de buxy ce
week-end pour la 25e édition du festival
une cinquantaine d'auteurs font le
déplacement le maire de la commune
commune jean marc loubry dullier sera
avec nous pour le présenter il se
produira le 6 octobre à la batterie à
guyancourt après une semaine de
résidence l'ex du membre des saïan supa
crew sly johnson est en tournée avant la
sortie de son quatrième album fond j'ai
dans son univers et ensuite du rugby en
ile de france les écoles de rugby et
réfléchissent depuis déjà 4 ans pour
limiter les accidents
nous irons voir l'une d'entre elles
[Musique]
c'est un rendez vous incontournable le
festival de bd de buc fait sa 25e
édition ce week end
l'occasion de rencontrer une
cinquantaine d'auteurs et de se faire
dédicacer son ouvrage préféré avec nous
en plateau jean marc le rudulier bonjour
bonjour alors vous êtes le maire de la
ville de buc 25e édition huit mille
passionnés qui viennent chaque année on
peut dire que c'est une organisation
bien rodée qui tombe bien oui c'est une
organisation bien rodée qui tourne bien
mais c'est une organisation lourde de
préparation on a commencé effectivement
il ya 25 ans au théâtre des arts call on
est monté ensuite au château parce que
le théâtre est trop petit puis le
château s'est révélé trop petit donc on
a mis des on a mis des temps que 500
mètres carrés cette année on met en plus
de la surface du château mille mètres
carrés de tentes dans le parc du château
donc ce qui fait que ben on accueille on
va pouvoir accueillir plus de 50 auteurs
cette année la première année nous
avions accueilli dix auteurs et puis bah
les les pronostics vont bon train on
veut battre les 8000 personnes de
l'année dernière les 8000 visiteurs qui
sont venus
certains disent on va dépasser les dix
mille pourquoi pas les gens étaient
nombreux et très tôt ils viennent très
tôt oui moi je peux vous dire qu'ils
viennent très tôt il y en a qui passent
la nuit du vendredi au samedi pour être
les premiers dans la file d'attenté du
gud de l'auteur qui va leur dédicacer le
livre qu'ils veulent faire dédicacer
il ya des gens qui dorment dans leur
voiture au pied de la porte du château
et qui attendent depuis une heure du
matin deux heures du matin trois hommes
atteints sachant que le festival n'ouvre
qu'à 10 heures les sont des passionnés
qui veulent voir des grands noms de la
bd s'est inversée al séverin qui a eu
l'honneur de dessiner la fiche
pour l'occasion il paraît réaliser une
fresque géante si j'ai bien compris il
va ils font ils font une fresque géante
mais il fait une fait une couverture
spéciale de la sortie de sang
sonde son livre qui sort au moment de la
bd où on avait des est avec la
couverture spéciale et le l'exemplaire
sera uniquement en vente sur le site de
la bande dessinée donc ça va attirer
automatiquement du monde je peux vous
dire qu'il n'ya que 800 exemplaires
c'est pour ça qu'il faut être dans les
premiers et donc ce festival c'est c'est
plus qu'une rencontre avec les auteurs
il ya aussi un volet pédagogique cette
année vous êtes tous ouverts au public
que vous dites empêcher alors il ya
effectivement un volet pédagogique avec
l'ouverture sur les publics en créant en
empêcher alors on a on a travaillé d'une
part avec les enfants qui sont
scolarisés est hospitalisé au chu taux
des coteaux loges en josas où
effectivement les enfants ont travaillé
avec un est avec un auteur teddy bellino
qui leur a fait faire un calendrier
et puis on a un autre style de publics
empêchés sont les détenus on a travaillé
effectivement avec des détenus d'une
prison de versailles de bois d'arcy et
de poissy qui eux aussi ont fait
effectivement un calendrier dont les
planches seront exposés lors de lors du
festival de la bd
et puis on a un troisième ce sont les
publics dits qu'ils sont
comment dire qu'ils sont oui je sais on
a travaillé avec le service
pénitentiaire d'insertion et de
probation des yvelines puisque on a des
personnes qui sont en liberté mais
surveiller quand ma main donc cela ils
sont venus au château de buc moi j'ai eu
l'occasion de les rencontrer et ils ont
travaillé avec l'auteur et rock et rock
c'est le dessinateur des profs la
fameuse bd des profs ils ont travaillé
ils ont fait une fraise qui sera exposée
dans l'entrée du parc du château aussi
je pense que c'est c'est amant cissé et
puis l'année prochaine et ben il ya des
objectifs de faire découvrir aux jeunes
la création d'une bd s'ils voulaient
alors avec deux collèges les yvelines un
collège
le collège georges-pompidou d'hors jeu
russe où il ya deux classes qui vont
travailler et qui vont travailler de
concert avec le collège blaise pascal de
plaisir ou deux autres classes vont
travailler et ils vont faire à ses
quatre classes et des leurs professeurs
et encadrée d'un auteur de bd
ils vont créer une bd là vous pensez
déjà à l'édition de l'année prochaine
qu'on voit que c'est vraiment une grosse
organisation mais il faut il faut
effectivement penser effectivement à
l'année prochaine moi je travaille j'ai
une directrice du pôle culturel de la
mairie de man amani sata mini qui chaque
jour me parle de la bd de l'année
prochaine voire de la bd de 2021 déjà
elle elle et elle est dedans
merci je marque l'originalité diminution
là c'est moi qui vous remercie
alors le festival commence dès vendredi
soir avec la projection du film dofus
livres 1 julitte vous pouvez retrouver
toute la programmation sur le site
internet qui sont qui s'affiche en bas
de l'écran un peu de musique
maintenant la batterie accueille en
résidence cette semaine le chanteur sly
johnson depuis 20 ans et s'inscrit dans
un mélange entre jazz hip hop et sol
il se produira samedi 16 octobre à 20h30
à guyancourt découvrait découverte de
l'article avec l'artiste avec isabelle
carré escos
[Musique]
on le découvre au sein du saïan supa
crew comme beat boxer trois albums de
disques d'or et une victoire de la
musique sa carrière est lancée
floriane
[Musique]
il collabore ensuite avec de nombreux
artistes comme camille pour son album le
fils en 2005
en parallèle cela et devint sly johnson
et entame une carrière solo avec son
premier album 74 en 2010 depuis il fait
pleinement partie de la scène musicale
française où il mélange les genres entre
hip hop jazz et soul
j'espère que comme un musique symbolise
le mélange en tout cas c'est j'aime ça
j'aime les rencontres
j'aime les mélanges donc c'est ce que je
fais depuis toutes ces années
si le public me ressemble en tout cas
c'est une bonne chose c'est mon
attention en tout cas son prochain album
soit en 2019 un réel retour aux sources
pour l'artiste originaire de montrouge
dans les hauts de seine pour faire
patienter son public il a déjà sorti un
ep le 28 septembre dernier avec trois
titres inédits dont skin ce qui me parle
en fait de cet épisode en école primaire
où je me retrouvais avec tous les autres
enfants dans la cour de récré et l'un
d'eux m'a malheureusement traité de sale
noir voilà et c'est ce jour là
moi je les prix comme ça que j'ai appris
j'étais noir du bon
donc je raconte cette histoire dans le
morceau ce crime
sly johnson se produira à la batterie à
guyancourt ce 6 octobre et à la cigale à
paris le 16 octobre
comment l'état compte ce week end saint
quentin en yvelines sera gastronomique
avec la 25e fête du miel de plaisir
organisé par l'association plaisir
village animations rendez vous samedi et
dimanche de 10h à 18h dans les communs
du château de plaisir 25e édition
également pour la fête des vendanges
d'elancourt l'association des amis du
passé d'elancourt vous invite à mettre
la main à la vigne en famille le
dimanche 7 octobre à la ferme du
mousseau vos enfants pratiquent le rugby
et font partie des 40 me licencier en
ile-de-france alors sachez que les
règles ont changé
le 15 septembre dernier le président de
la fédération française de rugby a
annoncé 14 mesures pour renforcer la
sécurité de la pratique de ce sport en
ile-de-france des dispositions déjà été
prises depuis quatre ans dans les écoles
de rugby avec notamment le toucher 2
secondes
le défenseur ne plaque pas mais se
contente de toucher son adversaire
celui ci a alors deux secondes pour
faire une passe au rugby-club de
versailles le sujet de la sécurité est
bien inscrit au favorise le jeu en
mouvement et on apprend les bonnes bases
aux plus petits nicolas d'andry s'est
rendu en bord de terrain pour observer
ses entraînements dans la formation du
joueur comme les ateliers que font les
petits on doit appréhender le lait peur
du contact pascal ory au début c'est la
première étape d'apprentissage apprendre
à ne pas avoir peur mais surtout
apprendre à ne pas avoir mal et à ne pas
se blesser justement et donc on fait des
petits ateliers où est ce que on apprend
à tomber en arrière sur le côté pour
apprendre à se protéger
on apprend sur le plaquage par exemple à
bien passé sa tête sur le côté avec la
tête calée sur la fesse qui est molle
pour ne pas justement se faire mal donc
en fait on apprend plusieurs mouvements
qui nous met en sécurité les enfants
et si vous cherchez de la motivation
pour courir nos repas vous propose les
foulées de maurepas au choix 6 au 12 km
au départ du stade du bois la course et
solidaire puisque deux euros par coureur
seront rap reversés à l'association
france leem
les inscriptions peuvent encore se faire
sur place à 9 heures avant le départ de
la course dimanche 7 octobre c'est
montigny qui fait son trail urbain cinq
courses différentes sont proposées du 13
km pour les grands 750 mètres pour les
enfants vous pouvez vous inscrire sur
place samedi de 16h à 18h et dimanche
matin avant la course au centre sportif
pierre de coubertin
[Musique]
direction le musée du luxembourg dans le
6e arrondissement de paris jusqu'au 27
janvier vous pouvez découvrir
l'exposition alphonse micha ne reste qu
une rétrospective de l'oeuvre de
l'artiste tchèquo style bien à lui
nicolas le herissier de nos confrères
via grand paris une jeune femme
séduisante la tête coiffée d'une
couronne de fleurs une affiche de
théâtre que le paris de la belle époque
s'arrachait littéralement c'est en 1894
que l'artiste d'origine tchèque alfons
mucha voit sa carrière décoller après sa
rencontre avec la comédienne sarah
bernhardt il travaillait sur une
illustration pour un journal
qui on va dire l'amener à dessiner sarah
bernhardt et il est en train de vérifier
cette petite illustration au moment où
sarah bernhardt arrive chez l'imprimeur
avec kiel il cale est l'illustration et
sarah bernhardt avait justement besoin
d'une affiche très rapidement pour son
prochain spectacle et du coup
l'imprimeur un peu pris de court proposa
de chaque était là de faire un essai
pour cette affiche et sarah bernhardt
ton se chargent de ce dispositif nouveau
le succès fou de cette affiche pour
sarah bernhardt a signé un contrat de
six ans avec micha un travail
d'affichiste publicitaire que l'artiste
laissera pour se consacrer à son oeuvre
majeure
une épopée slave une série de tableaux
classiques retraçant l'histoire du
peuple tchèque même chasse et surtout un
style bien reconnaissable qui séduira
les grandes marques emballages de
parfums biscuits ou savon mischa est un
artiste prolifique il s'inspire de son
propre passé de sa culture
cela tout ce côté doré le coût pour la
mosaïque les formes très bien s'il
souhaitait qu'ils se posent les unes à
côté des autres en a plaqué en même
temps ce côté un peu japonisant de cette
forme en kakémonos 13 ans auteur très
très dessinées avec des couleurs pâles
et face évocatrice figure majeure de
l'art nouveau ses créations sont si
célèbre que l'on parle même de style
micha pastel photographie ou encore
sculpture une magnifique exposition qui
met en lumière l'incroyable diversité
des oeuvres de méchas et c'est la fin de
ce numéro de votre cette ut loisirs
merci nous avoir suivis et rendez vous
la semaine prochaine pour de nouvelles
et des sorties
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
oh